STAY WITH US.
WE START WITH BREAKING NEWS.
♪ ♪
DOES NOT WANT DAVE 561.
DESPERATE TO DIRT, ANY
DIRT
ON DONALD TRUMP.
THEY ARE FRENETIC.
THEY'RE GOING TO THE WELL 70
HOURS.
MICHAEL: MET WITH THE
PROSECUTOR.
ONE TIME TRUMP ATTORNEY PLED
GUILTY TO A CHARGE OF LYING TO
CONGRESS OVER SOMETHING CALLED
THE MOSCOW PROJECT.
HE IS NOW CLAIMING THAT THE
TRUMP ORGANIZATION CONTINUED TO
NEGOTIATE THE FINANCE BY RUSSIA,
THE NAME LISA TRUMP DEAL OF A
POTENTIAL BUILDING IN RUSSIA
DURING THE 2016 ELECTION
HE SAID DISCUSSIONS HAD ENDED IN
JANUARY NOW YOU SAY IN IN
JUNE.
THE MEDIA OF COURSE USES THESE
ANONYMOUS SOURCES.
THEY ARE SAYING THAT COHEN
ALLEGEDLY TOLD INVESTIGATORS
SHADING A DEAL IN MOSCOW TO
MAYBE GIVE VLADIMIR PUTIN A
$15 MILLION PENTHOUSE IN THE
PROPOSED BUILDING PROJECT THAT
DONALD TRUMP WASN'T PAYING FOR.
THAT THAT RICH OLIGARCHS WOULD
LIVE THERE.
IT WOULD BE A STUPID IDEA.
THE PRESIDENT NEVER HEARD OF ANY
SUCH DEAL.
BY THE WAY, THIS DEAL, IT NEVER
HAPPENS.
THE PROJECT NEVER GOT OFF THE
GROUND.
NO TRUMP ORGANIZATION
INVESTMENTS WERE EVER MADE AND
TODAY THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION HAS
NO BUILDINGS IN RUSSIA.
YOU WOULD NOTE IF YOU'RE
WATCHING THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA.
EVEN IF IT HAD HAPPENED, THE
MOST FASCINATING PARTS, THERE IS
NO CRIME.
NONE WHATSOEVER.
DONALD TRUMP WAS A REAL ESTATE
MOGUL AND NEW YORK, THAT IS WHAT
HE DID HIS WHOLE ADULT LIFE.
HOW HE MADE A LIVING.
HE INVESTED IN MANY COUNTRIES.
BY THE WAY, DOESN'T EVERY
POLITICIAN THAT GETS PAID WITH
OUR MONEY, DON'T THEY GET PAID
WHEN THEY ARE OUT CAMPAIGNING
FOR THE NEXT ELECTION?
LEE 2017, THIS PROJECT WAS
WIDELY REPORTED EVERYWHERE.
REPORTED BY EVERY OUTLETS.
FAKE NEW CNN, "ABC NEWS" ."
ALMOST EVERY OTHER NEWS NETWORK.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE KNEW THIS.
THIS IS NOT A STORY.
IN ANY WAY IS THIS A NEW STORY.
DESPITE REPORTED EXTENSIVELY BUT
THAT DOESN'T MATTER TO THE LEFT.
IT DIDN'T MATTER TO ROBERT
MUELLER.
HE IS MORE INTERESTED IN MAKING
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA BUBBLE AND
FAIRS LIKE ALKA-SELTZER AND HE
IS JUST DESPERATE.
ALL HE WANTS TO DO IS MENTION
RUSSIA.
ALL OF THEIR ENTITLEMENTS      I
ALL OF THEIR ENTITLEMENTS      T
ALL OF THEIR ENTITLEMENTS      L
ALL OF THEIR ENTITLEMENTS      I
ALL OF THEIR ENTITLEMENTS      E
ALL OF THEIR ENTITLEMENTS      C
PEOPLE.
UNDER ANY CIRCUMSTANCE PURCHASE
WE CAN MENTION RUSSIA.
BREATHLESS REPORTING, GIVING
CREDIT
TO ITS NEVER ENDING WITCH HUNT.
BY THE WAY, ROBERT MUELLER IS
PLAYING YOUR MEDIA WITH THEIR
BIAS IN THEIR HATE OF TRUMP JUST
LIKE A FIDDLE.
WATCH THIS.
SPEAK TO SHAKESPEAREAN BECAUSE
SOMEBODY WHO SAID IT WOULD TAKE
A BULLET FOR DONALD TRUMP.
HE IS NOW POINTING THE GUN.
MICHAEL: COULD BE THE MOST
TERRIFYING PERSON FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
THE SINGLE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
PERSON FOR DONALD TRUMP GOING
FORWARD.
>> I BELIEVE IT.
>> REACTION FROM MICHAEL: WHEN
THE NEWS BUT MICHAEL COHEN WAS
EXACTLY WHAT WE AS PROSECUTORS
ALWAYS HEAR FROM MOB BOSSES.
THE COOPERATOR IS LYING.
HE IS SAYING THESE THINGS ABOUT
ME THAT AREN'T TRUE.
THIS IS KIND OF PLAYING OUT
EXACTLY LIKE A SIGNIFICANT
COMPLICATED ORGANIZED CRIME
PROSECUTION WOULD PLAY OUT.
>> EVERYTHING IS AIMING AT THE
PRESIDENT PERSONALLY AND THAT
HAS TO BE VERY UNSETTLING.
>> Sean: THE TRUTH IS PUTTING
ASIDE ALL THE REPORTING FOR
PEOPLE WHO SAY THERE A FAIR AND
BALANCED OBJECTIVE.
EVEN IF MICHAEL COHEN'S TIME
WHEN REVELATION WAS ACCURATE.
LET'S SAY IT IS.
BUT IT WAS IN JANUARY,
2 OF JUNE.
NO CRIME WAS COMMITTED.
EVER.
IT WOULDN'T BE A CRIME.
LEGAL SCHOLAR ALAN DERSHOWITZ IS
GOING TO JOIN US IN JUST A
MINUTES.
HE SUMS IT UP PERFECTLY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> ALMOST ALL THE INDICTMENTS
SECURED BY ROBERT MUELLER HAVE
EITHER BEEN EITHER BEEN
INDICTMENTS OF PEOPLE LYING THAT
IS FOR COMMITTING CRIMES THAT
DIDN'T OCCUR BEFORE HE WAS
APPOINTED BUT OCCURRED AS A
RESULT.
OR FINDING FINANCIAL MISCONDUCT
BY PEOPLE WHO ARE UNRELATED.
UNRELATED TO THE PRESIDENT WERE
UNRELATED TO THE RUSSIA PROBE.
THIS NEW DEVELOPMENT WITH
MICHAEL: SUGGEST THAT THERE ARE
GOING TO GO AFTER POLITICAL
ISSUES AND NOT JUST CRIMINAL
ISSUES.
>> Sean: HE IS DEAD ON
ACCURATE.
BY THE WAY, HE IS JUST TELLING
THE TRUTH.
WHATEVER HAPPENS --
MAY BE AN OLD-FASHIONED BUT I
BELIEVED AND CLIENT PRIVILEGE.
IF HE WAS IN FACT WORKING FOR
THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION, HOW CAN
MUELLER AND COHEN BREAK A
MANDATE?
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE IS NO
CRIME.
DESPITE ALL OF THIS THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE OF THE TRUMP AND RUSH
OCCLUSION.
NOTHING, ZERO.
TONIGHT WEIGHT AND ON THE
VERDICT WITH SOME PRETTY HARSH
WORDS PARTICULAR.
>> HE IS LYING ABOUT A PROJECT
THAT EVERYBODY KNEW ABOUT.
WE WERE VERY OPEN WITH IT.
WE ARE THINKING ABOUT BUILDING A
BUILDING.
I DECIDED ULTIMATELY NOT TO DO
IT.
THERE WOULD'VE BEEN NOTHING
WRONG IF I DID TO IT.
IF I DID DO IT, THERE WOULD'VE
BEEN NOTHING WRONG.
HE IS A WEAK PERSON AND NOT A
VERY SMART PERSON.
HE HAS HIMSELF A BIG PRISON
SENTENCE AND HE IS TRYING TO GET
A MUCH LESSER PRISON SENTENCE BY
MAKING UP A STORY.
HERE'S THE THING.
EVEN IF HE WAS RIGHT, DOESN'T
MATTER.
I WAS ALLOWED TO DO WHATEVER I
WANTED TO DO.
>> Sean: WILL CORRECT THIS
ISSUE.
THE SYNDROME IF YOU WILL, HOW
MUSCULAR'S OFFER DEALS.
TELL US THIS.
YOU CAN TAKE DAY ADDITIVE GEL
CARD.
BREE GIULIANI ALSO WEIGHED IN.
HE SAID MICHAEL COHEN'S LINE.
JUST NO SURPRISE THAT HE IS
LYING TO CONGRESS, HE IS A
PROVEN LIAR.
HE IS TRYING TO GET OUT OF A
LONG-TERM PRISON SENTENCE.
HE HAD BANK AND TAX FRAUD.
LOOK, I KNOW MICHAEL: .
HE HAS A WONDERFUL FAMILY.
I CAN'T IMAGINE THE PRESSURE
THAT HE IS UNDER.
I'M NOT GOING TO PILE ON.
HE HAS A LOT OF HARD THINGS THAT
HE IS FACING BUT THIS IS
IMPORTANT.
IF THIS IS MUELLER'S BIG
WITNESS, WHICH IS FAIR TO ASK,
WHO ARE WE TO BELIEVE?
MICHAEL: DONE OR THE MICHAEL
COHEN NOW.
THAT IS A FAIR QUESTION.
THIS IS THE LATEST EXAMPLE OF
WHAT HIS EFFORT IS TO TURN THE
SCREWS ON EVERYONE WHO WAS EVER
ASSOCIATED WITH
PRESIDENT ROUHANI.
LET'S LOOK AT THE LIST.
MICHAEL FLYNN, HE PLED GUILTY
TO LYING TO INVESTIGATORS.
THEY RUN HIS LIFE AND HE HAD TO
SELL HIS HOUSE.
THEY PROBABLY THREATENED TO
SKATE AS MY GUEST.
GEORGE PAPADOPOULOS, HE IS
SPENDING TWO WEEKS IN JAIL.
LYING TO INVESTIGATORS.
HE WILL NOW HAVE A FELONY ON HIS
TRACK RECORD.
PAUL MANAFORT HAD A BOOK THROWN
OVER HIM.
LET'S SEE, FINANCIAL CRIMES
DATING BACK TO 2007?
BANK LOAN APPLICATIONS, TAXES,
NOTHING BRUSHING.
NOTHING.
IT IS AMAZING IS YET A
COOPERATION DEAL THAT ENDED
LIKELY BECAUSE HE WOULDN'T LIE
LIKE CORSI WOULDN'T LIE.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
PAUL MANAFORT TONIGHT IS WILLING
TO RISK DYING IN PRISON THEN LIE
AS THE PROSECUTORS WOULD WANT.
CORSI WAS ON THE SHOW LAST
NIGHT.
HE WAS ON THE RADIO SHOW FOR A
FULL HOUR TONIGHT REJECTING
ANOTHER LYING INVESTIGATORS PLEA
DEAL.
HE MIGHT DIE IN PRISON.
HE IS 72 YEARS OLD ASKED MIKE HE
COULD HAVE GOTTEN TO GET OUT OF
JAIL FREE CARD AND HOW HE IS
UNDER HIS MICROSCOPE POTENTIALLY
FACING LIFE IN PRISON AND DYING
IN PRISON LIKE PAUL MANAFORT'S.
AS HE HAD LAST NIGHT ON MY RADIO
SHOW, HE IS WILLING TO DO THAT
BECAUSE HE CAN'T LIE BEFORE HIS
GOD.
THAT IS WHAT HE SAID BRITT HAS
FAITH WON'T LET HIM.
ROGER STONE IS ALSO LITERALLY
FEELING THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
WRATH.
NONE OF THE MEN I JUST MENTIONED
TO YOU HAVE PLED GUILTY TO
ADMITTED TO ANYTHING RELATED TO
RUSH OCCLUSION.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE OF ANY RUSH
OCCLUSION, NONE OF THEM ARE
BEING TRIED FOR ANY CRIMES
RELATED TO COLLUSION.
561 DAYS OF WATER?
HERE'S THE PROBLEM THIS IS WHERE
WE GET TO THE MATTER.
WE HAVE TO ANALYZE THIS DEEPLY.
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS SENSITIVE
SEEKING TRUTH AND JUSTICE,
INSTEAD OF APPLYING OUR LAWS,
EQUALLY APPLYING OUR LAWS.
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
WHAT YOU ARE WATCHING IS A
SPECIAL COUNSEL THAT HAS SPUN
OUT-OF-CONTROL, LEFT WAY BEYOND
HIS MANDATE.
LAYING JUST PERJURY TRAPS AND
LITERALLY TRYING TO COERCE
PEOPLE INTO WHAT WE CALL LYING.
IN OTHER WORDS, HE IS TELLING
PEOPLE.
IF YOU SAY WHAT HE WANTS.
CORSI GIVE ME FULL DETAIL.
JUST TELL US.
YOU WON'T EVEN GET PROBATION.
IF NOT YOU WANT TO DIE IN JAIL.
THAT IS THE CHOICE.
TO THINK HE IS SAYING, I'M NOT
GOING TO LIE AND I WON'T LIE.
I BELIEVE IN GOD AND.
I'M NOT GOING TO DO IT.
IT IS SIMILAR TREATMENTS.
SEMI POBLANO KILLED AT LEAST 19
PEOPLE.
HE GOT OFF ON NO JAIL TIME AND
THEN HE HAD TO LITERALLY
TESTIFY
AFTER THAT HE WAS REWARDED.
NOT ONLY DID HE NOT GO TO JAIL
BUT HE WAS THE WITNESS
PROTECTION PROGRAM WHEN HE GOT A
NICE NEW HOUSE IN ARIZONA.
ISN'T THAT NICE?
19 PEOPLE.
NO TIME IN JAIL.
MEANWHILE, IF YOU ARE NOT A
NOTORIOUS GANGSTER OR A TRUMP
ALLY, THE WHEELS OF JUSTICE ARE
TURNING DIFFERENTLY.
GUILTY LIKE THEY'RE GOING OUT OF
STYLE OF.
THEY CAN GET THE UNDERLYING
CRIME OR THESE PEOPLE TO SAY
THINGS THAT THEY DON'T LIVE TO
BE TRUE.
TOP DEMOCRATS, DEEP STATE
BUREAUCRATS.
THEY LEARN THEY GET AWAY
SCOT-FREE.
I HAVE THE LIST.
LOOK AT THE LONGTIME CLINTON
AIDE.
SHE LIGHTLY LIED WHEN HE TOLD
INVESTIGATORS THAT THEY HAD NO
KNOWLEDGE OF HILLARY'S PRIVATE
EMAILS.
REALLY?
IS THEY ACTUALLY EMAILED.
EFRAIN REPORTED HERE ON THE
FOX NEWS CHANNEL,
CATHERINE HERRIDGE REPORTING
EITHER DOJ OFFICIAL BRUCE OHR OR
GLENN SIMPSON LIKELY LIED DUE TO
THEIR CONTRADICTORY TESTIMONY.
THE DOSSIER FROM CHRISTOPHER
STEELE, AND ONLY DID HE STEAL HE
LIED IN LENGTH AND WAS FIRED BY
THE FBI.
GUESS WHAT?
HE WAS WORKING STILL WITH BRUCE
OR, THE FOURTH MOST POWERFUL GUY
AND NOW WE HAVE NOTES THAT SHOW
THAT HE WAS TRYING TO BE BRUCE
OHR AND HIS WIFE, THEY'RE TRYING
TO FEED INFORMATION TO ROBERT
MUELLER.
MEANWHILE, HE DOESN'T EVEN STAND
BY HIS OWN DOSSIER.
IN AN INTERROGATORY IN
GREAT BRITAIN.
LET'S GO TO THE VIDEOTAPE.
HE LIED UNDER OATH ABOUT
NATIONAL SURVEILLANCE PROGRAMS.
SO TO JOHN BRENNAN.
HE ALSO LIED UNDER OATH ABOUT
LEAKING.
JAMES COMEY LIED UNDER ORTH.
HIS SECOND-IN-COMMAND, ANDREW
McCABE.
HE WAS ACTUALLY FIRED BECAUSE OF
HIS PATTERN OF LYING.
WHERE ARE THE FEDERAL CASES
AGAINST THESE LIARS?
AGAINST THESE PEOPLE.
THEY LIED TO CONGRESS.
INSTEAD, WE ARE PUSHING FOR
CHARGES, WE ARE FIRING COLBY AND
HE DEFENDED IT.
HE SAID, I LIED.
YOU CAN STILL BE A GOOD PERSON
IF YOU LIVE.
WELL, LESS OF ARE REPUBLICAN AND
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT YOU IN JAIL
THEY'RE GOING TO PUT YOU IN JAI.
>> HE WAS FIRED FOR LYING
MULTIPLE TIMES WITHIN THE FBI.
YOU DEFENDED HIS CHARACTER ON
TWITTER.
THAT IS OKAY.
LYING IS OKAY?
>> DOES NOT OKAY.
THAT CASE ILLUSTRATES WHAT AN
ORGANIZATION THAT IS COMMITTED
TO THE TRUTH LOOKS LIKE.
I ORDER THAT INVESTIGATION.
WE INVESTIGATED AND HOLD PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE.
GOOD PEOPLE LIVE.
I LAID OUT ON THE BOOK, I THINK
I'M A GOOD PERSON.
I STILL BELIEVE ANDREW McCABE
IS A GOOD PERSON.
HE FOUND THAT HE LIED AND THERE
ARE SEVERE CONSEQUENCES IN THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FOR LYING AS
THEY SHOULD BE THROUGHOUT THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> Sean: GOOD PEOPLE, THEY
LIVE.
THE ONLY PROBLEM IS, THEY'RE NOT
GIVING MULLER WHAT HE WANTS.
HE WILL BE CHARGED WITH PERJURY.
YOU WANT REAL RUSH OCCLUSION, WE
GOT IT WITH ALL THE EVIDENCE
THAT HE DOESN'T HAVE ABOUT DRUM.
WE HAVE THE FIXED EMAIL
INVESTIGATION, VIOLATION OF THE
ESPIONAGE ACT.
THE BIGGEST DESTRUCTION OF
JUSTICE CASE I'VE EVER SEEN.
THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
HILLARY CLINTON.
LIED TO VOTERS AND COMMENCE
VOTER SUPPRESSION IN TRUMP'S BED
IN MOSCOW SO THAT THEY WON'T
VOTE FOR THEM.
I WONDER HOW MANY AMERICANS
DIDN'T VOTE FOR HIM BECAUSE OF
THAT LIED.
DEFIES A FRAUD AND ABUSE, LYING
TO JUDGES.
LITERALLY A FRAUD EXTRAVAGANZA.
OF COURSE, ALL NATIONS THAT
DON'T EVEN TELL THE JUDGES THAT
HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
WE HAVE INSURANCE POLICIES,
LEAKING POLICIES, IS ROBERT
MUELLER GOING TO LOOK IN THAT
DIRECTION?
I THOUGHT WE WERE LOOKING FOR
THE TRUTH.
WE HAVE EVIDENCE ON ALL OF THIS.
IT IS A SLAM-DUNK CASE.
WHY IS HE NOT?
THERE IS ONE SET OF RULES IN
THIS COUNTRY.
ONE GROUP OF AMERICANS, THESE
PUMP PREACHERS, IF YOU ARE A
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT OR YOUR NAME IS
CLINTON.
ANOTHER SET OF RULES FOR
EVERYONE ELSE.
TRY
THIS AT
HOME.
YOU ARE SUBPOENAED AND YOU
DELETE THE EMAILS, YOU ACID WASH
YOUR HARD DRIVE.
YOUR DEVICE IS BUSTED AND SOME
CARDS ARE TAKEN.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU.
I DO NOT WORK.
IN OTHER WORDS, WE DON'T HAVE
EQUAL APPLICATION OF THE LAW.
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
THIS IS A TWO-TIER JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
HE WAS AN AMERICAN, EVERY
AMERICAN TONIGHT.
IT SHOULD SCARE YOU.
IF THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THOSE WHO
SURROUND HIM OR SUBJECTED TO
WHAT IS NOW CLEARLY A DOUBLE
STANDARD POLITICAL PERSECUTION.
NOBODY IN THIS COUNTRY IS SAFE.
NOBODY.
THIS IS A UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
WE ARE NOT A BANANA REPUBLIC.
AT LEAST WE'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO
BE.
THIS IS NOT OUR CONSTITUTION AND
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE IS SUPPOSED TO
WORK.
WE CAN DO BETTER, WE BETTER DO
BETTER.
WE LATER DEMAND BETTER.
WE WILL HAVE MORE ON THIS
THROUGHOUT THE SHOW.
FIRST, WE TURN TO A NETWORK
WHOSE MOTTO IS ABOUT AS FAKE AS
THEIR COVERAGE.
CNN, FORCED TO FIRE A LONGTIME
CONTRIBUTOR.
ONLY AFTER WIDESPREAD OUTCRY
OVER HIS ANTI-SEMITIC RANT
DURING A SPEECH AT THE U.N.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> OF YOUR STANDING WITH THE
PALESTINIAN PEOPLE, WE MUST
RECOGNIZE THE RIGHTS OF AN
OCCUPIED PEOPLE TO DEFEND ITSEL
ITSELF.
WE MUST PRIVATIZE PEACE.
WE MUST NOT ROMANTICIZE OR
CRITICIZE IT.
COMMIT TO POLITICAL ACTION.
GRASS ROOTS ACTION.
LOCAL ACTION.
INTERNATIONAL ACTION.
THAT WILL GIVE US WHAT JUSTICE
REQUIRES.
THAT IS A FREE PALESTINE.
FROM THE RIVER INTO THE SEA.
>> Sean: AND CASEY DON'T KNOW,
ISRAEL IS LOCATED BETWEEN THE
JORDAN RIVER AND THE
MEDITERRANEAN.
HE WAS LITERALLY REPEATING A
CALL FROM TERRORISTS AND
PALESTINIAN EXTREMISTS.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU WIPE ISRAEL
OFF THE MAT.
HE WAS ULTIMATELY FIRED,
LITERALLY DISGUSTING FAR LEFT
RHETORIC.
THEY DID NOTHING.
THEIR HATRED FOR THE PRESIDENT
AND EVERYTHING THAT HE
REPRESENTS, THE FACT THAT HE WON
HAS DRIVEN THIS NETWORK INTO A
VERY DARK AND FRANKLY SCARY
PLACE.
DAY AFTER DAY AND MINUTE AFTER